robert habeck und annalena baerbock sind
die neuen und die alten vorsitzenden der
grünen
sie wurden heute beide mit großer
mehrheit wiedergewählt allerdings
erreichte annalena baerbock ein deutlich
besseres ergebnis als harbeck ski bekam
das beste ergebnisse sie eine
politikerin seit gründung von bündnis 90
die grünen erhalten hat nämlich 97 1
prozent
robert habeck kam auch auf über 90 beide
haben vorher ihren bewerbungsreden
gehalten und darin deutlich gemacht
worum es ihnen in den nächsten zwei
jahren zu diese gewählt sind geht
annalena baerbock hat eine tour durch
alle wichtigen themen gemacht wird die
außenpolitik angesprochen sich für eine
europäische armee ausgesprochen sie hat
über syrien gesprochen dort ihre
forderung nach einem stopp von
waffenexporten in die türkei
unterstrichen es ging auch um
wirtschaftspolitik und um vieles mehr
robert habeck blieb in seiner rede sehr
viel abstrakter es wurde nicht so
konkret er hat vor allem die künftigen
aufgaben der partei darin gesehen zu
regieren mutig voranzugehen hat er
gesagt um die herausforderungen der
zukunft zu meistern
darin waren sich übrigens beide
parteivorsitzenden einig dass es nun
darum gehen müsse die verantwortung auch
wahrzunehmen und tatsächlich die partei
auf das regieren eigentlich stimmt
vielleicht sogar auf die eroberung des
kanzleramtes